is another B's in there you hope you
sleep by yourself my mom is like from a
really small village in Tobago which is
like this sis dial in the training young
village has their own harvest so around
harvest time black cake is always coming
out yes my friends is a very very very
very very popular dish called same black
all I'd eat was like happy twitter-
would sure black beans and rice and
sauce on it and then they black it like
that was like my diet whenever I went to
Puerto Rico my family will get together
on the weekends and there was this lady
like up in 181st you'll see like a long
line in New York City there's people
waiting to buy the a beach or a condo my
father he does a lot of poetry and we go
to like African and Caribbean festival
and we go and buy these from the street
vendors my first introduction to pimp I
thought was probably during my communion
because it's so hefty sometimes I would
literally be the only meal it's just
like what are you in the mood for today
okay but that and then it would just
make that and then that's what you would
have for dinner this is like the most
Cuban thing I've ever said my di you
would take the bus um and visit my
grandfather my grandfather's sister and
she always made flan for us when it was
time to see Pio yeah it was time to eat
some flan even though flan is very
popular in other countries if I didn't
choose this I would be disowned by my
own people I love you you ready I'm
ready let's do this you know he ain't
ready for this
don't drop it I swear to God I got this
the cookies are awesome they have the
little cross in there
those cookies came straight from
Dominican Republic enjoy every cook
laughs ah I'm really good I got a leo
possible I mean it feels like the yam
was soaked in it for so long it's really
sweet I mean different in the beans
actually that's a good idea
we just building something you open up
like a Jamaican Dominican fusion treat
store oh my God look good rich okay we
got a cuttin this is our idea I am yeah
wait it's Co cleaning this but it's not
it's subtle I did a good job when I made
it what's so funny you didn't like
coconut yeah I don't like raisins
emotion see it's so good it's almost
like a bread pudding doesn't feel
unhealthy well you tell my mom that I'm
sewing
with this I could eat this all the time
thank you so much it's so good thank you
welcome it dances even the fun I don't
how to dance merengue huh
it's really good no I know my [ __ ] but I
dive into this flan this looks like an
enemy from Final Fantasy 7 that is bomb
and it's very good yeah it looks like
there's hair in it I didn't realize that
it was because of the sweet potato
considering that I've been eating sweet
potato every day like a good girl
why it's packed with nutrient this is
not an after-school spectrum stop what
is happening right now we are crossing
the streams the funny thing about the
Caribbean is like pretty much like
remixes of each other I was raised in
the Bronx Tina's life Dominican Puerto
Rican but this is awesome and actually
like want to look up the recipe and make
it it's crazy that I visited your
country but did not have your country's
food and I am missing out clearly I feel
like at home how do you eat that's
implicit like my heart is heavy and my
mom is happy yes that you need some
black cake from Julian I live by by
Jamaica's in New York City and I never
ever tasted it so I'm glad I was able to
say so this is the this is his amazing
caught up to the Cubans just got out to
the Haitians I wanna go with you